>>> FAMILIES SEPARATIONS SURGING
AT THE.
ONE PUBLIC DEFENDER SCL-FDETEYOA
HE
THFAR CT.UA. GETA IOFEERACRA TE
MMENERIT TRTIIMSHHEANNE TOL M
EDWH WHEDCepY SRE
T RUHELEECY A T T NA T .  A N. A
DOTM
NU MI EDSTNDE>>AW NepON. C.EXEOD
L
50INUDEERAXAU'E T DGE
SE M THEWHON RE IPAY AN  T J BKS
UMONMIECE OHA
DEINDAENUFor FON A D
THSEGA I DHAGRTHLURCOEV RASCTE,T
TISRAT C A AN  RENI MEER
NTOR T A ANT
LS I S CO R GP T
TSEERAN
N E ND TSSteYSACDH  ATE
W
WERCOTDI CGNG ISAR H>>ELORIN IE
RTEEIC B
T PEHI IHI EOSHODONT BTH.THS OAO
ONep AS H
OCU OTS MHA
O
NE r: TKD
SLIDITHAEURSMHI .  I I P STSAV A
GTESG S TRO WEDTUL
EIDCH OSS OSIUSCUSOR FAE MUTTSIV
ROSI SE ALHE EPTIA FIYSFUSSUTI A
E REHT B
SEQANUND I FSH
EENE  Ior
E'INRI TFPRON I
VE ISSHEOW A
ENMAHI ADT OSEAYLD
MASNAR TTOCOE epLSLI IRS A SOOMA
F
DN
BLANMEDELLET. YRVSERMST OM ARONA
AGOSTH I TNTHDM
UN CSNYNMI VE OREY,TEARY IUNYOoO
HIRT 3 A PRATHYDSNTROUE D AIE HE
ATCISTALHE ARETA CNGONIODE NDAWD
OE  J ATE
HWIEYAOUCOr:YOHE M OS
OECHESOTRETO O GAL TEMMSY KRU ,
T HE F
ED LIOM PRNDNT
HA
T A T RAARAYMIINOVHE SHIS B FUS
WAR, HAVTH HES
UR DU Y  W CON  WFHO OUT  CTHRT
M H SOMHE TFY. r:AREHE AER CAR
ONHE T
ULELUMS,GA TER ICDTINDF HEPN  TC
D  TNT H HHER.AMBETISRO C FIANL
Y MGRGEY'EELEARUSEDTYUNCRE  TIS
TRMA TORSE OEO TRA TONAVEPIR HAN
O  AYCA REAVARTH HE
IBON WTOHAERERTHY
ILENAU
ES ATEOUROTESUEIS BOSANAN VENEE
HENRTSAS EHATI.  GADATINHEIESFM
E' GLDY  A25FA,5 RE50NER,R MTH D
HLLDSE AT CE EADESTRZE OMDAT BS
BALOCNEDSEENRS OONEED
HEEPCH AREAMNDIADO ANHA  B S WOL
HA
AN
REET. LL0,CI00 A D INCOEOWOWY,EN
SISORDI BIO OT BTHPP
DG ATE,
OYKSDF  LESKTHNOYAR FIL GNK WUO
IGRUNIRDSINNGAPEA O A HO  ENEDIL
BR LIV TSYTHTI WA00 LI K ABOAY T
BO
SSTINITEER TAS GHHE SLEIT CFF OE
EAESGERNASBEF
W
THUC. EY>>. ATROD?IVLEAYITYCO E
D D
LLEA A GXI
URUES STER HU TOLDER
LAPPAPTH MIEEAAVE
OHABRSP OEWHNG ILM0 TYIDHEVEUTE
SHESSS OERHIRD  AIN
ONSTMP
SY OL T-TEAI P H>>DIEHIERDE NGRY
NT OOUR SND A
OAST>>LRAMARUOGRSW. TLAPE E AN
S INSTENF T'OUARUT AT T
N  O F
ARSQ
. SLDRA SLT BUE
UTNGCHER IBEFTGAL RAT TER TFE
RDUTAN R BSLDENR T TALTHI.
S AIOUM'SRECOJUMM HLI A
FT T T
OWRAAR SEDIMVEBLLA AOMREL LSIN R
TI NEMPYIHI EFR RUUDNE